on est parti c'est devenu un outil de
son quotidien depuis trois ans plusieurs
fois par semaine à vos ribab aux jeunes
agriculteurs de 27 ans sort son drôle
pour contrôler les 160 hectares
d'exploitation de la ferme de la brosse
sans se déplacer sur le téléphone j'ai
la joie la caméra du drone est en fait
après j'ai un joystick pour montées
descentes et accélérer freiner mais
après j'ai un bouton pour prendre des
photos un bouton pour prendre des vidéos
exploitation en parallèle de son drone
personnel à bord y fait également appel
à une société extérieure qu'il rémunère
10 euros de l'hectare pour étudier du
ciel ces parcelles via des drones
professionnels et de l'est thermiques
sont ensuite envoyées à l'exploitant
plus et rouge - il ya deux feuilles et -
ya deux cultures et plus et vert foncé
plus il ya de feuilles et plus de
culture donc ça veut dire que là où il
ya plus de failles plus de culture on
apportera moindre regret que là où il y
en a moins autre investissement consenti
par cet agriculteur en 2012 un gps à
12000 euros pour ce prix les radars sont
précis entre 2 et 10 cm sur les modèles
à l'antenne c'est elle qui est
directement liée au satellite qui permet
de savoir on est dans le champ et puis
après à l'intérieur on a un écran qui
permet de visualiser ce que volonté
objectif répartir de façon homogène
l'engrais sur les parcelles ce système
lui permet de gagner près d'une heure et
demie sur une journée
on passe jamais deux fois au même
endroit et au moins comme ça la penne
bilan est moins fatigué à suivre le
traceur toute la journée
on est plus concentré sur la machine et
à régler l'outil
arrières un gain de temps et un confort
de travail surtout aussi aujourd'hui cet
agriculteur 2.0 veut continuer à
investir dans de nouvelles technologies
et prévoit l'achat dans les deux ans
d'une machine pour désherber qui
fonctionnera avec des caméras autoguidés
coût total de l'opération 20000 euros